you
[Music]
my name is Aneesh I'm work at trifecta
which I'll explain a little bit more
about what they do but what I'm gonna be
talking about today is something called
programming by example which and it's a
little bit specific to try fact in the
sense that I'll be going over the story
of how we integrated it with our
application but it's a methodology that
can be applied to a lot of different
data applications and might be a new way
for users to actually interact with data
so hopefully everyone can get something
out of it all right so a quick overview
so I'll just you know first explain what
programmed by example is I use the
acronym PBE so that's the one acronym
you might have to remember I'll talk
about you know algorithms to kind of
solve it because it is this theoretical
problem and there's actually like ten
years of research on this so it's pretty
exciting from that domain I'll talk a
little bit about No okay I'll talk about
like integrating it so all the
challenges that come from integrating
something that's like this theoretical
algorithm into a data application that
end-users non-technical users need to be
able to understand and use and then
finally all I'll talk about how we make
it something of an ml driven feature and
like how we integrate analytics into the
feature itself because one of the values
that we have at trifecta is start with
the user and the users interaction with
our application drives a lot of our
product in other ways so it should be
the same for this feature ok there we go
I said the point so a little bit about
what trifecta is we're a data
preparation platform a lot of you guys
might have heard this quote that it
designed to spend like 80% of their time
cleaning their data and only 20% of the
time actually do it native science and
whether or not that's true in any one
specific case there's a lot of value in
making the data cleaning and data
wrangling part much smoother and much
easier for users to deal with so the way
it works is that trophy
- kind of sits between the a lot of like
different import sources so you can see
at the bottom there's like icons for
files we support reading from databases
we support a lot of cloud vendors as
well and all of that data we import into
trifecta
users then clean their data they can
wrangle their data and it's all done in
a standardized format and then finally
whenever they're ready to you know go do
visualization go to analytics on it we
publish their data to the source that
they you know want us to so for example
we can publish to tableau if they want
to do visualizations we can publish to
data robot if they want to do some
automatic machine learning and so
sitting in the center gives us a lot of
flexibility because we can connect to a
lot of imports or tsa's and export
sources so how do users actually clean
their data when they're interactive we
have this page that we call transformer
and it's very similar to excel in some
ways I'd like to describe it like that
for people who aren't familiar with like
data products but as you can see it's
like a tabular format we have a lot of
nice like visualizations at the top
these are meant to kind of guide the
process of oh if you have like missing
values in a certain field what the
format's of different columns look like
these are all things that help with the
data cleaning process the way that users
kind of interact with this data is
primarily through a script like
interface so all you guys have done
sequel I'm sure or at least familiar
with it it's similar to sequel it's a
DSL a domain-specific language that's
built for trifecta but a lot of the
operations we support are things like
you know Maps and mathematical
operations aggregations a lot of the
similar stuff to actually what John
Ferguson talked about in the first talk
and yeah and that's like the bin so far
the primary way that people interact
with data you define an operation you
run it and then you get the results in
this view one thing I will point out is
that this is a sample of data so this
application actually runs as a web app
and because we're limited by like
Chrome's memory requirements we can't
load your several gigabyte table into
memory and Chrome
we can do is load like a sample of five
to ten megabytes and whenever you're
comfortable editing that sample and
whenever you're you've gained confidence
and what you've done with your data you
can then run this script as a job on the
rest of your data and another thing to
point out is that we don't touch the
original data as all it's all copied and
so you don't have to worry about like
you know data permanence or anything
like that so data cleaning this is like
a term that means a lot of things but
one of the the challenge I'm going to
talk about today is this challenge of
standardization which has like a million
different meanings but in this case what
I'm talking about is standardizing a
bunch a column that has like a lot of
differently formatted things into a
single format so in the example given
it's unfortunately little hard to see
but there's a date column with you know
things in different mmddyy formats and
suppose that what you'd like your data
to look like is to have this date column
be in one single format so right now
before we looked into this thing called
programming by example we have we had a
little bit of like pre-existing
standardization functionality but it was
very specific and involves a lot of
custom code and it ended up being sort
of brittle and sort of specific to dates
so this is kind of an example of what a
user would like to do and right now in
our product it's like a very limited use
case our challenge was to kind of
generalize this yeah so to drill down a
little bit further let's say you have a
column of phone numbers and they all
have very funky formats and you'd like
to make them look the same and add an
international code to the beginning this
doesn't sound like a very hard problem
but in practice it can actually be
pretty confusing there's a lot of edge
cases that you have to handle and
there's a lot of like funky rhetoric
stuff that you have to do for this like
one simple Saturday zation task and so I
went on Stack Overflow to try to figure
out how you would do this in sequel and
this was the third answer down what's
funny about Sacre feels like the
first answers usually like a really
short pithy thing and then like every
answer below is like wait no that
doesn't work so every looks like finding
problems with it and it turns out
there's a lot of like edge cases that
this kinda script has to handle so if a
user wants to do something like this in
trifecta or in any data application they
often have to write this like long
script out themselves which might be
okay for technical users but for
non-technical users it's definitely a
problem it means that they would have to
find a technical user to be able to do
this and that is a lot of you know
overhead as you can imagine so what if
instead of writing that script you
simply type out what you want your phone
number to look like and then have
everything happen immediately that would
be pretty awesome right if you could
just type out plus one nine four nine
seven two seven six four nine Oh with
the spaces and have the rest or column
be like immediately formatted so that's
what programming by example kind of is
so in PvE rather than specifying your
program so like your sequel script or in
trifecta our language rather than
specifying that directly you specify
these things called input output
examples where for any given record of
your input data you type out exactly
what you want the output for that
example to look like and then the
Machine actually figures out the program
that you're trying to do and
automatically applies it so this is like
it's sort of a declarative way of
interacting with data there's tons of
research on this and so what we tried to
do a trifecta was implement it because
we had been getting a lot of like
feedback from users that hey I you know
just want phone numbers to look like
this what's the series of
transformations I need to do to do it
and it would lead to a lot of like
headache and pain whereas if they're
able to just type out exactly what they
know they want the output to look like
it's much easier so yeah so I'll talk a
little bit about the algorithm because
very cool parts of it and the algorithm
here is basically given a set of input
output examples what's the program in
some domain-specific language be it seek
will be it
or even beat whatever - that would take
you from those inputs to those outputs
so the way that most ppl gorillas were
is in two steps the first step is to
synthesize a set of programs that could
theoretically represent that input
output example and usually you know you
end up synthesizing quite a few programs
but let's go through an example so let's
say that you have Harry and Hermione
over here and you're trying to get their
initials so a pretty simple task and as
you can see there's two input output
examples that let's say the user has
specified you can also imagine cases by
the way these are single cell inputs and
singles all outputs but you can
generalize this whole idea to multiple
column inputs and multi-column outputs
as well but let's say they've provided
these so the first step is let's figure
out all the programs that could possibly
go from Harry Potter to HP Hermione
Granger to Hg so the three programs that
listed because people are very far so
one of them is concatenated the first
character the first word with the first
character the second word if you imagine
that we have some kind of language that
supports like string concatenation and
character lookups this seems like a
pretty simple program and would probably
be the correct one but there's other
ones that are that also do the same
thing right so the second one is
concatenate the string literal H with
the first character of the second word
and the example given both of their
names start with H so it would suggest
that as a valid program and then finally
an even more ridiculous one if the word
is Harry then H P otherwise H G so these
are all three potential programs that
the synthesis step could recommend
because these all are theoretically
consistent with the examples provided
but as you can see the second and third
ones are pretty terrible and they
wouldn't generalize well to like any
other name so that's where ranking comes
in
please
okay so the idea behind ranking is you
simply use some kind of metric and we'll
talk about a little bit of the
heuristics and m/l that can go into that
process but you're basically trying to
pick the program that's most likely to
be what the user intended and also most
likely to generalize to the rest of
their data so in this case obviously
like the best program is simply to take
the first characters of each words and
concatenate them so these are kind of
the two modules of every of most PB
algorithms that have kind of come about
but there's a big problem with synthesis
so generating all the programs that are
consistent with a set of input-output
examples is not only like the DSL could
be not only so vast that it's impossible
to even like go through all them but in
a lot of cases it's like straight-up
unbounded you know there's a lot of
reasons why that might be you might have
like a large function catalog at
trifecta we support like 200 functions
and sequel and a lot of these languages
support a very very large amount of
functions if you're trying to just like
brute-force search like every possible
program you can come up with up to a
certain depth and then just check if it
works with input-output examples your
users gonna be waiting for centuries
right you're like looking through way
way too much stuff and there's things
like nesting you might be suggesting
programs that are multiple steps and the
American string parameters can be like
whatever how do you search over those
and there's a lot of like optimization
tricks you can use here you don't have
to do a brute-force search but even so
it becomes very very unperformed to try
to just synthesize everything so the way
that most kind of PV algorithms get
around this is with the observation that
when people are using this tool it's
usually because they're trying to format
strings and that's like been the biggest
use case so far and that's something
that is a little restrictive in some
senses but in a lot of senses it makes
things much easier because the domain
specific language for dealing with
strings can become very specific to like
things like formatting so you have
things like concatenation upper casing
lower casing sub strings regular
expression matches and those kinds of
things you can optimize very heavily
over and then
like come up with an algorithm that's
very very good at synthesizing programs
for those so this is definitely what
like pretty much every algorithm the
last like ten years has kind of gone
through and so at trifecta we sort of
initially like started out with this
method of just like okay let's try to
just write a better string format by
example but you know down the road it's
definitely something that we're trying
to look at is to how can we extend this
DSL to be what our trifecta DSL is which
is a much much bigger set of operations
of math schema aggregates yeah so
assuming we're starting from a string
formatting DSL then okay
yeah so few few algorithms real quick
the first one that you guys might have
heard of is that's in Excel 2013 is
flash Ville this was kind of like the
first real implementation of programming
my example is whose previous the guy who
wrote this gowanni is considered by many
to be basically like the inventor of
programming by example he works at
Microsoft and his research and basically
enabled this feature to happen the way
it works is that it's you you take like
it takes input output examples and it
supports a string DSL that has a bunch
of formatting operations turn Aries and
loops and it's pretty good you can try
it out in Microsoft Excel if you want
it's available for free it's available
in a lot of other Microsoft products as
well power bi powershell power query i
think and this was kind of a good first
like stepping-stone for a lot of
applications but one thing that kind of
happened a few years later was that
people realize that well if you're just
learning on the examples that users have
provided then you're oftentimes going to
be like very sadly mistaken as to what
the user is actually trying to do the
reason is that like input data
be very vast and very heterogeneous
right you might have like a user
providing examples for let's say a
certain format of phone numbers but the
rest their column might be filled with a
completely different format of phone
numbers and if you only learn a program
based on the examples that give you then
you're necessarily going to be missing
out on a lot of the additional context
about what they're trying to do just
because they didn't put in the right
examples so the way that blink fill
which was an algorithm in 2016 came
about this is well let's like do some
kind of search over the input data the
entire input column come up with some
kind of representation of the different
like regular expression patterns that
could be in that data and like some of
the logical patterns is what they
describe it as and then use that as a
data structure and inject it into the
synthesis algorithm to basically like
inform what the generated programs can
be that are also valid for the entire
column so this also has the benefit of
like very dramatically reducing the size
of the DSL and being much much faster in
flash fill so if you play with like
flash fill and Excel I think on average
it takes like 0.1 seconds to generate a
column of data from or to generate a
program from an example but with blink
fill you could end up with something
like point zero zero three seconds when
we tested it so we went down this road
and we tried to implement it there
wasn't an open source implementation
available unfortunately but we just did
it in Python and it turned out to be
pretty pretty nice and then yeah so that
kind of those were two like algorithms
that have proven to be pretty good on a
set of like real-world Excel string
formatting tasks but one thing that we
have been struggling with is the ranking
step so just to quickly talk about like
a few of the ranking strategies that
some of these algorithms used the very
simplest thing you could do is what they
will refer they'll reference Occam's
razor which is basically the idea that
user is trying to do the simplest
program possible right so these are two
examples in
trifectas DSL they're both doing the
same thing you're taking the substring
of a column from indices 0 to 2 but
clearly the first one is just doing
unnecessary stuff you don't need to be
taking the substring and merging them
just take the substring and specify the
indices correctly and this is kind of a
contrived example but it's pretty much
like the only heuristic that you really
really need but you can go you can go
more more in-depth with this right so
there's like a lot of other heuristics
you can use when you're actually ranking
beam and basically the way that it would
work would be that the ranking algorithm
would choose a program that satisfies
the most of these heuristics so you can
you know prefer a certain function
catalog you can note that when you're
trying to extract text for example your
user probably wants to extract them
between two delimiter x' so prefer
programs that are doing that as opposed
to like other crazy regex manipulation
stuff a very obvious one is to use like
metadata about the column to inform what
kind of functions should be available or
not so these are great and blink fill
does a lot of them but they're still
kind of brittle and one of the questions
is can we rather than like custom
writing a bunch of ranking methods and
heuristics that end up being just a
bunch of if statements can we like
improve them by looking at user data and
so an architecture that you could
imagine is something like this where
once you've synthesized your set of
valid programs and let's say in blink
fills case you're synthesizing a much
smaller set because your informed by
data from the column as well you extract
features from each program and basically
like create a feature vector for each
program that may be encode some of these
heuristics as values and then you
basically like have a model that
predicts off of each vector what the
likelihood that it is the correct
program is and using that you get a
highest ranked program that's informed a
little bit more by user data because you
can train these models to basically say
what's the likelihood that given this
set of like heuristics of a program that
is a correct one and there's a lot of
like ranking algorithms out there
there's a lot of ranking models out
there so the ones that we commonly use
that try factor or logistic regression
but we're starting to look at some more
sophisticated ones and CRFs are kind of
interesting because CRFs or hmm any kind
of graphical model model that represents
the dependencies of our features would
be nice but this kind of approach is
something that might be good because it
allows you to custom tune a lot of
heuristics but it leaves the actual
prediction step up to a model that's
hypothetically trained on user data so
that's pretty awesome but there are some
challenges here so first is well you
know the training data itself is
something that's should actually be
pretty easy to generate if you're in a
data product where people are doing
transformations on data what you can
simply do is take a look at the data
before a transformation is applied take
a look take a look at the data after
it's applied and then have those be
input output examples and the
transformation that actually was applied
is the correct label for whatever model
you're choosing and in theory if people
are doing operations on your product
that's where you want to get training
data from because that's gonna be better
than any kind of large data set it's
going to be personalized to what people
are actually doing in your product and
so that was kind of one of the things
that we set up at try facto was a feed
of people's like interactions and a
record of input output examples that
come for them however that is definitely
not great if you're trying to not save
like personal information so this SSI
and credit card numbers email address
they show up in data that comes in very
fact all the time and we can't save
those analytics pipeline because we'd be
like you know breaking a lot of laws but
what we can do is this idea that okay we
don't really care about what the
specific values of some of these fields
are we just care about like in from a
string sends what is the logical format
of them
so for example one two three four five
six seven eight nine let's say that's
your social security number you don't
really need to know that those are the
exact digits when you're trying to learn
that transformation all you need to know
is where the digits are and where the
delimiter czar and so this kind of
masking has helped us a lot because
we're able to kind of save data that's
based on format and not actual user data
and from the models point of view
hopefully because we still have access
to what the patterned transformation is
doing we're not actually like losing any
information here so this is like one
strategy that is sort of helping us
right now but in theory we'd also want
to have some kind of online trained
model that can train directly on users
data in their browser but that is not
sending any data back to us so making
that guarantee is is definitely an open
question yeah so that brings us to some
like really cool stuff now because over
the last 10 years there's been a lot of
work at neural programming by example
so the idea is you know rather than
doing synthesis rather than doing this
ranking what if we can simply generate a
program step by step given some encoding
of input output examples and this avoids
a lot of the headache of like
restricting your DSL potentially and can
given the results of generative models
on a lot of text it seems like it's a
pretty cool approach there's a lot of
things you can mean by outputting
program here right so you know you could
be classifying from a list of programs
so this could run after some kind of
heuristic model but you could also just
write out a program like token by token
if you know that your program comes from
a fixed set of you know tokens you can
basically just output them one by one
and train an R an end to do this another
like strategy could be to output a
vector in an embedding space and then
you know use like nearest neighbors to
find the closest program that satisfies
the constraint that it's valid over
these input up examples so these are all
like different kind of potential
approaches
have all been tried to various degrees
but one thing I will point out is that
this is a different problem than program
induction which is a very cool idea
where you can train a neural network
that goes from input data directly to
output data in our case that doesn't
work because we're trying to learn a
program that's reproducible and
interpreted by the human we already know
what they want the a potato to look like
we need to figure out the program not
just get the output data so yeah so
we're bus fill was kind of the first
like well one of the first attempts to
do like neural program by example in
this way the way it works is that you
take your input up you take your input
examples and you take your output
examples and you basically encode them
in some like character way feed them
through lc-ms and you output your
program token by token this is for one
input output example pair but you know
for multiple ones you need something
that basically can look at all the
programs as they're being outputted and
the way the paper did this is with like
a pooling step and a classification step
afterwards so it's generating each
examples has a program being generated
token my token but then those at every
time step that gets fed through another
layer to actually predict what the most
likely next token is so this is great
but you know how do you make sure it's
valid over the examples because there's
not a guarantee anymore and the way that
they approach this is in the decoding
step beam search is this like common way
of like getting the most likely sequence
of output tokens they modified it to
also enforce this constraint that the
output result is consistent as as
consistent with the examples as possible
so there is a slight level of potential
failure in this case because you even
with like a very large beam you still
might end up with a place where the
neural network just can't predict a
program that's correct but it was able
to do pretty well on most the tasks that
flash Volyn lengths were
yes and the one thing is that the DSL in
this case is the string concatenation so
that part has stayed the same so some
good things about this it's continuous
space so something that's really cool is
that when users are like entering data
entering examples in your product it can
actually handle noise potentially much
better than a lot of these deterministic
methods so typos that someone might
enter in there examples might not throw
off the network as much as other like
methods would and yeah I mean
potentially could be trained on data
directly no need for any kind of like
heuristics there some cons though so
it's hard to interpret the results
we definitely have run this problem with
like other probabilistic models where a
big part of our application is
interpretability and everything that
happens to people's data we want them to
be able to see and interact with and
play with with things like robust fill
it's definitely a lot harder to do that
there's a lot of research that goes into
like neural network interpretability
and testing but it's still kind of an
open question and again it's hard to
verify that this will always work so a
few trade-offs but yeah so another
another really fun thing that we've run
into with other like deploying other
neural networks is how do we do it in
users browsers in a way that scalable
performant doesn't slow down our machine
too much how do you make sure that the
prediction step happens in scaleable way
so I try factor the way that we've
implemented all of our data operations
is through an engine called photon which
is basically a c++ in-memory thing that
compiles into web assembly and runs on
people's data in a far more performant
way than like raw JavaScript would but
how would you then take something like a
deployed model let's say intends our
flow and run it in the same way yeah
where do you store the weights so memory
is always like
concern and testing it's it's a little
hard to make guarantees on something
that's inherently probabilistic and one
of the metrics that is very commonly
used in PVE is how many examples does it
take to output a correct program and
would you get any guarantee that give it
enough examples you could end up with a
correct program or not
and then finally usability so is there
some way that a user could provide
feedback to the operation of the system
besides simply doing it on more and
having the network be trained on more
data so these are all looking questions
these are all things that were like
investigating but it's it's definitely
something that brings a lot of
challenges when you're trying to
integrate it into a custom application
and yeah and so the the final thing I
want to talk about is like just the user
interface because this also led to a lot
of like really fun questions there
hadn't been really too much work in user
interfaces for PVD in the past there's
some like ad hoc tools Excel of course
has a pretty simple interface for us
what we did was we started with a
prototype of what the interaction model
could look like and preview ability is
very important in our application so in
this gift the way it works is that as
you're typing in your output example the
program is generated and then run on the
rest of your inputs so you can see
exactly what's happening to your data as
you're interacting with it which is very
important but when we move it to our
main application we did the same kind of
procedure so this is like basically a
set of inputs on the Left
outputs on the right users entered two
examples for extracting the field of an
address and slightly grayed out are the
program's kind of attempts at figuring
out what the user trying to do but it
raises a lot of questions so in the rest
of our product we allow things like
sorting and filtering and searching can
we do that here with some kind of tool
bar and more importantly if we know that
the user should be entering examples for
a certain type of format
is that something we can prompt them to
do somehow so this like led to thoughts
of clustering perhaps based on pattern
format and it was interesting because we
were developing a feature called
like we were developing an entity
resolution feature at the same time
standardization and a lot of the kind of
questions that we were asking here were
the same as the ones that they were
asking so yeah some more fun stuff let's
say our ranking model is giving way to
everything right then we would be able
to get the top and most likely programs
not just the top one should users be
allowed to potentially select between
them if we're for some reason you know
maybe the top one isn't exactly what
they want but it's the second highest
ranked one that they're actually trying
to choose should they be able to like
interface with PVE somehow and select
that should they be able to edit it is a
big one if the program especially is not
very interpret Abul should they be able
to edit it at the same time as providing
examples or is that too much user
confusion and how do we handle when
things go wrong so a lot of questions
but a few takeaways I guess from what
we've learned so far so programming
example is really cool there's
definitely a lot of opportunity there
and it could potentially be the way that
users in the future prefer to interact
with data maybe not everyone but there's
definitely a lot of people who know
exactly what they want their data to
look like they want to be able to type
it out and you know assuming we can
extend it beyond things like string
formatting there's a lot of opportunity
for this kind of like automatic
synthesis and m/l and heuristics
something we've kind of learned because
this is one of this is a feature where
we've been trying a lot of algorithms
and one of the things we've learned is
that there's definitely trade-offs in
Express ability and determinism so ml
gives you a lot more power potentially
but there is always like a little bit of
interpretability and determinism gap and
the opposite with heuristics
and building it requires effort from a
lot of different people yeah so
hopefully we're better than this and
that's it so please do check out
trifecta comm you can play with this for
free it's gonna be available the
programming by example stuff is gonna be
available in a few weeks and if you go
on to our cloud product online you can
import data from your like computer and
then just play around with it it's
completely free to use for the basic
version of our product and feel free to
reach out if you have no more questions
hi there thanks for the talk
I got that I got the point that it
doesn't scale very well if the number of
possible functions is large what about
if the input is large so let's suppose
you're doing let's say constructing like
JSON or XPath expressions on you know
medium sized Technic JSON or XPath I
think XML documents would that would
that work or would that be intractable
that's also another scalability issue
yeah thanks for bringing that up I think
that one is a little bit more dependent
on the language itself so if you have
like if you're outputting JSON and you
have a very nice program that's not
trying to output things token by token
but in this case is operating directly
on the fields then it might be a little
bit less of an issue but for us it
definitely turned out to be a big one
because if the input record is very
large we're doing a lot of like regex
matching across the thing to figure out
what's possible and yeah that becomes
another like scalability concern
[Music]